calme et paisible le lecteur de croire y
va il est encore plus aujourd'hui
l'internât est fermée depuis hier à
l'origine de la fermeture un problème de
santé qui a affecté plusieurs élèves
mardi
mais moi je et puis mardi et 6 passes et
15 minutes
ses toiles c'est déjà arrivé
la première est à combien d'élèves qui
ont eu ce problème à votre avis 10
heures une dizaine d'élèves
au total une quinzaine d'élèves se sont
présentés à l'infirmerie mardi après
midi
c'est là que la direction de
l'établissement a pris la décision de
fermer l'internât
il est en effet deux hypothèses à cette
épidémie de problèmes intestinaux
la gastro-entérite ou l'intoxication
alimentaire
j'ai pris la décision ferme et
l'internât on a appelé tous les parents
pour qu'ils viennent récupérer leurs
enfants hier soir par mesure de
précaution donc on est parti sur
l'hypothèse en fonction des maux de
ventre et de l' alerte du bulletin des
restes d'une gastro entérite
comme ce sont des maux de ventre et
qu'un certain nombre d'élèves prennent
leur repas dans l'établissement soit en
interne et en 2000 pensionnaires on n'a
pas exclu d'être confrontés une
possibilité de
d'intoxication alimentaire donc on a
prévenu les services de l'état donc
sanitaire des prélèvements de repas ont
été effectuées et les résultats des
analyses seront connus demain matin et
communiqué aux parents l'internât
restera fermé jusqu'à vendredi